Why would I believe you? You lied about
Waco. Either post medical documents or
stay quiet.
And unfortunately, I have to say
he won on that one. He he certainly did
win on that one. It's just him.
>> him. You're [laughter]
You're the only one
>> Parry wins. He won. He just won. He just
totally won. This is [__]
>> your ass, brother. [music]
>> Yeah, this guy's like friends with like
a whole bunch of like multi-millionaires
and they really can't put together to
pay for his pay for his [__]
They have to beg a fans. So, guys,
friend of the stream, friend of the
channel
Purple Parry Gaming
has just got a
what? 3.5 million view tweet
that's being responded to by just about
all all the worst people you can
possibly imagine. Literally all the
worst people on earth, okay? Why is the
cut bad again? It's just [__] dude.
There's nothing I can do. There's
nothing I can do. It's [__] It's
[__] What can I do?
Nothing.
The cut's [__]
It dried weird.
And it's all [__] up. It's not worse
than the first day. It's not worse than
the first day. I don't know how you you
literally just tripping if you think
that. It's just not worse than the first
day.
It's just uh
my [__]
gray streak is dry as [__] Oh, there
are products in it. My gray streak My
gray streak just gets dry as [__] Not
been a week since the haircut yet. A few
more days, it'll be fine. That's facts.
Oh, the back is just totally [__] The
back is totally [__] from the cut.
But that's been That's been the way it
is. I've just been hiding it well. I've
just been hiding the back well.
The back is like thick in the middle for
like no apparent reason.
Anyway. It's not even plugged Purple
Parry Gaming, friend of the channel, has
got a 3.5 million view tweet.
Okay? All the worst people you can
possibly imagine, all the worst people
in any social media platform, are
responding to it. It's totally over. We
have to sit here and justify Parry's
[__] dog [__] rage bait with a
response
because Wendigoon and Umperium and all
these other [__] retards are
responding to it.
Just shave your head at this point. I'm
not shaving my head. It'll grow back
It's growing back in. It's going to be
fine.
>> your head at this point, come on.
>> past it. We're getting past it. We're
brute forcing through it.
Okay, so we're justifying Parry's dog
[__] rage bait. I'm covering his face.
Justifying his dog [__] rage bait with a
response. So, let's have a look. What
did he say? What do you have to say
about Brandon Buckingham?
This fellow who's in hospital right now,
apparently with like multiple organ
failure or something.
He said he had like multiple organ
failure. He's got like sepsis. He's got
all sorts of [__]
He's He's drinking
What is it? [__] it. What's it called?
Lean. He's drinking lean.
He's drinking lean and doing fent.
And he off the perc.
So, he's in hospital. Okay? He's in the
hospital now.
He He's on the purple drank. He hitting
the sizzurp. The sizzurp.
And he's in hospital now cuz he was
hitting the sizzurp and the and the
fetty too hard.
He was hitting the sizzurp and the fetty
too hard. He's in the hospital now.
Okay.
So, let's take a look. What does
[laughter] Parry have to say about this
horrific situation for which he's raised
$350,000 on GoFundMe?
It's not even plugged in. Dude, look at
the dudes. Dude, holy [__]
This is what they mean when they say
white people wasted, yeah? It's not even
plugged in.
It's not even plugged in.
It's not even [__] plugged in.
>> So, um I don't know if you guys can see,
there's actually like two identical
pumps here. There's like two identical
machines.
Apparently they're running on battery,
too. This one does seem to be switched
off. So, I don't know what Parry's point
is meant to be here. I think he doesn't
care what his point is here. I think
he's just going in on it because he
thinks he can get away with it.
Holy [__]
It's not even plugged in.
It's not even [__] plugged in.
Yeah. It's not even [__] plugged in.
The wires are going to it. The [__]
blue wires are going to it and it's not
even [__] plugged in.
It's Oh.
What?
Dude.
Okay. I don't know how I don't know how
confident I am. It's a scam.
>> [__] Thank you.
>> However confident I am, that's gone up
like 10% man.
Dude.
It's Yeah, there's no beeping. There's
no beeping.
But he's connected to it with all these
wires.
>> There's no beeping, guys.
>> Dude, look at the dudes. Dude, holy
[__]
So, there's the clip. There's the 3.5
million view
clip, guys.
Millions enraged by this by this clip.
By the lamest
mock detective work you've ever seen.
Let's have a look at some of the
brilliant intelligent responses here,
guys.
So, it's just like people pulling up
other tweets he's made. You're a commie.
The only commie is Brandon asking people
to pay for his drug rehab. Okay.
Getting absolutely dog walked them out.
I doubt Brandon walks his own dogs. He's
rich. He can pay someone to do that.
Not going to lie, if you're right about
this, holy holy hell, is that completely
insane? If you're wrong about this, you
have to delete every piece of social
media you have, YouTube, Instagram,
Twit- Facebook, Twitter, Instagram
overnight. If it turns out Brandon's
telling the truth, he should apologize
anyway for not giving us the proper
proper evidence and medical documents in
the first place. You just make it too
obvious at that point, man. Like the
idea that anyone still responds after
that is [__] absurd.
Anyway, where's the Wendigoon tweet?
And Wendigoon and Umperium and Willy
Slaktjaw
and every other [__] [__] that
quote tweeted this. Every other [__]
[__] that justified Parry with a
response. Yeah, I was saying this
earlier, like I wasn't going to cover
this Brandon Brandon Buckingham [__] I
wasn't going to cover Parry's gay [__]
about it. And then retards like
Wendigoon just handed him this.
Just replying to obvious bait.
Crazy that you also rented out a
hospital for us to visit him in. This
goes deeper than we thought. Wow.
You re-owned this guy, Wendigoon. You
re-owned this guy, Wendy.
Like Green Garry here says, "Why would I
believe you? You lied about Waco. Either
post medical documents or stay quiet."
And unfortunately, I have to say
he won on that one. He He certainly did
win on that one.
Wendigoon did lie about Waco. That is
facts. Where's Umpy's tweet? I don't see
Umpy. Yeah, so he says um "I can't
believe you're a real person, haha. So
[__] stupid and evil."
Just like can't detect the trolling at
all. Totally filtered on it.
And Parry replied
"How many children did Noxtaco expose
porn to
while you co-hosted a podcast with him,
do you think? More or less? Hundreds?
Thousands?" So, like I say, it's just
like all the worst people you can
possibly imagine piling in embarrassing
themselves
and handing Parry just like stupid wins
for no reason.
And I can't believe I'm forced to cover
it. I can't believe I'm here covering
it. How mentally ill do you have to be
to make this up about someone who's
verifiably in hospital by all of his
YouTube friends? It's Thanksgiving, you
piece of [__]
So, just how stupid on every level is
this?
Not recognizing it's a troll, first of
all. That's step one, okay?
Not realizing it was posted before
Thanksgiving.
Step two.
Step three, not realizing that
Thanksgiving is a purely American
holiday that no one in [__] Malta
gives a [__] about.
Great. Thanks, Willy. Thanks for your
[__] input, Mr. Slaktjaw.
Your Israeli wife is very proud of this
one. Your Israeli wife, I'm sure, is
clapping and screaming at this one.
Slipping and sliding on her seat over
this one.
>> [laughter]
>> So, where was this reply?
"Post an MRI proving you have a brain."
And he's got a response here as well,
apparently. It's always these small
channels making up conspiracy theories
and demanding people to bait them.
Genuinely scumbag business model.
So, just unimaginably filtered,
unimaginably baited.
Yeah, hu- human bowling ball handed
the the easiest strike of his life.
"Liar meatball Maltese." From Gamma
here.
And guys, I have great I have
unfortunate news for you. I have
unfortunate news for you.
The slop tuber videos have begun.
Sly Boy
this fellow who recently uploaded a
video claiming that YouTube loves rape
because they took down one of his videos
has uploaded a video
talking about Parry
called He Slandered Another YouTuber for
Clicks. So, let's take a look, guys.
What is the unimaginably filtered
take on this? What is the knuckle
dragger take on this?
I'd like to think I put in a good effort
to get facts straight on this channel.
And in the occasional times when I have
gotten some details wrong, I usually try
to correct the record. So, you can
imagine I raised an eyebrow when I got
the comments
>> suspecting his wife, guys.
>> Now, a couple days ago I put out a video
titled pray for Brandon Buckingham in
which I spread the word about a very
serious
organ failure situation.
A very serious organ failure situation.
That was such a YouTuber sentence. [__]
me. What am I becoming?
The organ failure situation is crazy.
>> You did that intentionally. This is like
a joke that you've written in you
[__] lying poser. Anyway, Brandon
Buckingham a creator who I've admired
for a long time is going through a
situation where all of his organs are
failing. Doctors are having a hard time
figuring out what the [__] is going on.
It certainly seems as though his life is
in imminent danger. This morning I woke
up to a comment. Turns out he faked the
hospital stay. Maybe look into these
Dude.
I can hear the the hiss on this guy's
audio.
And it's
people a little more before you
advertise their GoFundMe. Now if the
YouTuber in the hospital were like Jack
Doherty or Neon, I would have
immediately I think I've irreparably
ruined my ears. I think to fiddling with
audio for the whole day today I've
irreparably ruined my ears and I will
never be able to listen to things
normally again. concerned I got egg on
my face. But this is Brandon Buckingham
who has a pretty sterling reputation on
YouTube. So I was certain this could
Jack before you advertise their
GoFundMe. Now if the YouTuber in the
hospital were like Jack Doherty or Neon,
I would have immediately been concerned
I got egg on my face. But this is
Brandon Buckingham who has a pretty
sterling reputation on YouTube. With
who?
With [__] people? With [__]
people? With the mentally disabled? With
who? With Wendigoon? With Turkey Tom?
With Umpervil? With the mentally
disabled? With the mentally disabled
community on this platform?
Is that who he's got to get with with
Sam Hyde?
With the mentally disabled rapist
demographic on this platform? Is that
who trusts him? Sorry, I don't I don't
assume that he's faking it, but
Yeah, did Brandon Buckingham get so
amazing reputation with all these
reputable people?
No, all the people who like Brandon are
stupid scum.
Actually.
case, but I thought I would go ahead and
do my due diligence. Now from what I can
tell the source of this theory that he
faked his stay at the hospital comes
from this individual on Twitter who
posted a clip of their own live stream.
Dude, holy [__]
It's not even plugged in.
It's not even [__] plugged in.
The wires are going to it.
The [__] blue wires are going to it
and it's not even [__] plugged in.
So dumb, man. This [__] is so [__]
stupid, bro.
It's not even [__] plugged in. It's
not plugged in. Oh my god, it's not
plugged in.
This guy is so [__] I don't know
how I don't know how confident I am that
it's a scam, but however confident I am,
that's going up like 10% man.
Yeah, there's no beeping. There's no
beeping.
But he's connected to the
wires. Sorry to make you guys sit
through this guy spamming the same like
five words over and over like he's some
[laughter] sort of NPC character
dialogue option. Perhaps this person
hasn't been to the hospital since he was
born out of his mom's butt. He seems to
think that if you're in one of those
little chair things it's like literally
keeping you alive like pumping your
heart and lungs. Now you may be
wondering is this trolling for clout or
is he just that stupid? I would err on
the side of trolling for clout although
allegedly according to him he's even
convinced some fans to refund their
GoFundMe donations because of this. I
guess today
I wanted to talk about
the same thing I I spoke about
yesterday.
Which is um
which is Brandon Buckingham
and the allegations against him. He says
allegations as if like people came
forward. It's just you.
>> [laughter]
>> You're the only one. He won. He just
won. He just totally won. This is
[__] awesome.
Um
So I, that is to say Green Gary, uh
posted a tweet
over the situation. It has just almost 2
million views now. Isn't that crazy
guys? Isn't that crazy?
You can really see what the motivation
is here. The the way he's kind of
rubbing his hands together in glee over
having 2 million views on some obvious
rage bait tweet is so [__] cringe,
dude. That's Buckingham that's Brandon
Buckingham
exposed for faking his hospital GoFundMe
scare. But you're making the video about
it. But you're making the video about it
and then he's going to do a whole
segment out of this video and not
showing medical
regarding his condition. And uh
basically it's the following This isn't
even performing well. It's got 2K views
in an hour. This is pulling like [__]
>> from my stream. The clip from my stream.
Right, there's this video here of um
Brandon. Like the fact there's no pulse
oximeter, the fact there's no beeping,
the fact that it's like a very strangely
quiet like the entire last hospital
doesn't make any sense.
This stream is a tough [__] watch. I
certainly did not watch the whole thing.
It's 6 hours. It's a 6 hour stream. He
doesn't really get to the point. He just
like rambles off into weird [__] but
skimming through it he has like some
really bizarre arguments like he says
it's probably a fake hospital set
because there's no beeping. I assume he
just like watched Dr. House or something
and that's his whole conception of what
a hospital is supposed to sound and look
like. fact that it's like a very
strangely quiet like the entire last
hospital doesn't make any sense.
That doesn't make any sense. What the
fact that the layout doesn't make any
sense? How does the layout not make any
sense? What did Did you have better
ideas to like organize the feng shui of
this hospital room or something? This is
a puppy You know, I actually tried to
argue with this guy. You know, I
actually tried to debunk what this guy
is saying. I showed this before this
year. I can't change this what they use
on puppies in order to uh
you know, train them to be house trained
and not pee indoors. Um
I guess he's but that's a real hospital
totally. Like what a waste of your
[__] time. What a waste of your
[__] day making this video, man. And
cutting corners
and they're buying puppy pee trainer
mats.
Maybe. Maybe. We don't I mean but it's
possible. I guess hospitals should be
investigated if it's real. But yeah, I
mean you know.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. I mean if this is the best
Brandon's uh
If this is the best Brandon's insurance
can offer
what does that say about Brandon?
>> [laughter]
>> Which is he says he wastes his money on
drugs realistically. Um That's his big
zinger is the mat behind him looks like
a
a mat used for puppies. I'm I'm going to
need a little bit more solid proof than
that. Wow, really? in like a really
weird odd completely unfounded
accusation that Brandon
has is broke cuz he spent all his money
on drugs. I have no idea where he thinks
he's getting that one from. Honestly,
yeah, the fact that it doesn't look like
he's in an ICU etc. etc.
And listen, if it's the case if a
medical expert can probably come in and
explain all of the situation like why
this isn't plugged in. It's not even
plugged in etc. A medical expert
probably could come in and give people
like me, right? You know, rational, you
know, good faith skeptics who don't
believe everything that's shown to them.
A medical expert could come in and
explain things are the way they are. And
you know who should be providing a
medical expert guys? You know who should
be providing a medical experts?
Brandon. Brother, I think he might be a
little preoccupied right now given that
his organs don't work. I think that's
maybe his first order of concern. But
once we get all of the organs pumping
blood and [__] again, I'm sure Brandon
Yeah, you really you spent your whole
Thanksgiving making a video debunking
Purple Perry Gaming. Great job, man.
Great job, man.
happy to go ahead and share the sheets.
I also love that he just fully admits
that for every argument he's made as to
why this is probably a fake hospital set
he he just fully admits some medical
professional can probably come in and
just explain all of this. So he knows
he's full of [__] He knows he's just
slinging mud and he's being blatant
about that fact to his audience as well.
He's also frantically tweeting about
this as much as he
one didn't quite get the same viewage as
the other a mere 5K views instead of the
where he retweets Brandon's video from
the hospital and says isn't it a bit
suspect how he refuses to show any
proof. He's a little busy right now. My
guy he's he's a little busy. I think. I
think he can sell the GoFundMe. time to
show proof or you're wrong and he is
a little engaged at the moment. You know
who should be providing a medical
experts?
Brandon.
This [__] [__] [__] clout
chasing [__] disgusting [__]
manipulative loser pedophile defending
[__] stupid [__]
drifter. Bro's brain just short
circuited for a second there. That's
about all the time I wanted to devote to
this. I just wanted to get on here and
kind of hawk digital loogies at this
person. It sounds like there's some
political undertones to this like maybe
he considers Brandon to be like on on
the wrong political side or something
like that. I'm not sure. So it's
possible that this is like bad faith
political brain rot or something. But
I'm leaning more on the side of just
blatant trolling for the sake of
controversy and getting eyes on his
channel which he you should not do. You
should not go harass him because if you
did that that would be another view for
him. So please don't. My gosh, sometimes
I
That sounds like something I would
I'm being I'm being real. Anyway, that's
about it. Uh bye.
Wow. Okay. Why is this [__] idiot
talking about it then?
Let's watch a bit of this [__] [__]
What did he I assume he replied to a lot
of the tweets today?
Is that the case he went over some of
the tweets on stream today? All the the
tweets about the the the response to my
tweet about the situation.
I'll do a follow-up about uh
situation. I think the most I mean it's
just
Anyway, anyway. So, yeah, let's get into
it, guys.
So,
Amorphous says, "Lmao."
And it's
a tweet I posted quote tweeting
a tweet by Marshall
saying in regards to the YouTube channel
Extra Credits. Got writers to believe
monsters and aliens represent minority
groups. Got games companies to believe
playing is a Nazi, endorses Nazism.
Got game companies to charge $70 to $80
for games.
To which I respond,
"Literally all of that is true
good." Um
And he answers, "All of that is true,
right? Monsters and aliens can represent
minority groups. I I don't want to do a
rehash of yesterday's stream, but we saw
it with the [__] Easterlings from
Lord of the Rings, man. It's It's a
Playing is a Nazi. If you're endorsing
the Nazis and saying Nazis are awesome,
yes, endorses Nazism. Now, is that most
games? No, but I think it's possible.
Like the idea I don't I don't like that
It's just a game, man. It's not a
political message. Like such [__]
[__] dude. And let's just be
[__] honest, games should be more
expensive. Video games should be more
expensive. Not the slop that's produced
these days, but good video games should
be more expensive, right? Most indie
Silk Song, it's actually [__] up that
they only charge $20. They are like
trying to [__] over other indie
companies. I've been saying this for
ages, right? Like the idea that like,
"Oh, wow, Silk Song is so kind for
making another game."
Is it like why I would [__]
This [clears throat] is such a stupid
[__] take. Things should be priced
at their value, the value the market
determines for them.
At the at the price point that raises
the maximum revenue for the for the
publisher, for the creator.
No?
Why would you moralize the pricing of a
[__] luxury product like a video
game?
Game so cheap? No, they are actively
[__] over Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's so gay. Um
No, they made it $20 in order to
undercut other indie companies and
basically like [__] over their business,
right? Because video games, and I'll say
this again, are [__] fungible, right?
They're not fungible in the way a
[__] apple is fungible, right? Like a
a sandwich is a
ham and cheese sandwich is the same as
any other ham and cheese sandwich. No,
they're not that fungible. But they are
more or less the same. If you see two
Metroidvanias with more two Dark Souls
style Metroidvanias, one of them is a
dollar, the other is a million dollars,
you're going to Well, but what if you
really like the one that's a million
dollars? No, that's not how it works.
Silk Silk Song should be more expensive.
It should be more expensive. They are
[__] over other indie developers um
for their own benefits, and they don't
need the benefits. They already made it
big with Hollow Knight one. They made a
[__] dog [__] game.
It's insane. It's [__] insane
that people just sit here and be like,
"No, no, they're so wholesome for No,
they're [__] over other developers. I
don't care Oh, but they're being nice to
consumers." Not really, cuz consumers
could just pirate. What the [__] are you
talking about? Or they can just not play
your stupid [__] dog [__] game.
They're not being nice to consumers.
They're just playing over developers.
It's not how it works. Obviously,
they're helping their own developers,
but that's, you know, I'm
They're like as an entity of the
producer. Anyway,
And yeah, like so what if [__] Mario
Odyssey 70
>> god, shut up, man. Stop giving us
[__] [__] takes. It's only Perry
has the most right Stop killing games.
The most righted takes ever. Stop Stop
killing games. Stop killing games. Uh
games should be more expensive cuz it's
morally right.
Wow.
You totally don't sound [__] [__]
right now.
You totally don't sound like a total
[__] [__] right now. Changing my
Mass Effect ending, that's Perry.
And people are a bit too They're a bit
stupid about this channel.
They're a bit stupid about this channel.
I feel like people are like over
overrating the issues with this channel.
Yeah, you know what? I'm winning against
his team now.
You know,
it's it doesn't help that the main guy
is
>> This guy is a [__] [__]
They don't need to be plugged in or on,
though. That's for giving multiple IVs
at once if they need multiple different
meds at once. Awesome. So, they just
happened
Zoob's being racist on YouTube. Hello.
Growing up during Gamergate 1.0,
Internet Blood Sports, and DramaAlert
Scorge was exhausting. Leave me alone.
It caused damage to the minds of young
people. I really This pisses me off,
guys. I've never liked LeafyIsHere. He's
like unfunny. It really pisses me off.
That guy is like a [__] That guy is
like an idiot. The guy is stupid. And
he's addicted to cocaine, much like
Brandon Buckingham is addicted to
Percocets.
What's this? They don't need to be
plugged in or on, though. That's for
giving multiple IVs at once if they need
multiple different meds at once.
Awesome. So, they just happened to go to
the further away IV. They just happened
to go to the further away IV, and it
doesn't have any beeping whatsoever.
That's really convenient. It's really
convenient. Like I can I mean is it
possible that this is happening in a
real hospital? Like I said, yes, it's
possible. But why should we take
Brandon's word for it when he has a
history of overexaggerating his content,
being extremely [__] viral
clickbaity, like [__] lying, [__]
exploiting [__] poor people, making
these We bought four consoles like we
Oh, we just like literally like make a
whole documentary. Made a whole
documentary about Sam Hyde where he like
ignores the fact that Sam Hyde is a
pedophile and just hangs out with chat
Sam Hyde, but he's a good awesome cool
guy. Like if Brandon Buckingham is known
to lie for clout, like by hiding the
fact that Sam Hyde is a pedophile in
order to clout grab Sam Hyde,
why the [__] would she Why why the [__]
would she would she Why the [__] should
we believe anything this guy has to say?
Like this guy just like [__] makes
these [__] clickbait Tyler Oliveira
style lying clickbait thumbnails. We
know Tyler Oliveira is known to be like
a fraudster. Basically, everybody says
it's very well known that he like lies
and doesn't give any proper evidence for
his videos. Um
You know, you can There's even a
WillyMac video about that. And Brandon
is the same. Brandon is the same.
He's just like clickbait [__] who's
more than willing to bend and I guess in
some cases break the truth.
>> I mean I guess I agree with Perry on
vibes,
but I've never actually watched a
Brandon Buckingham video, so I can't
tell whether he's correct on fact. The
only thing from Bran- Brandon Buckingham
I ever watched was his Mass Effect
interview, and that sucked, and that's
why I hate him.
If it helps him clout wise, like in
these sneaker situation, for example,
for example, um So, yeah, I I don't
think there's like any reason why we
should like take for granted. Like why
would I have a If you guys don't know, I
had a debate with Aiden about this. So,
you know, Aiden Aiden Projects, million
subscriber YouTuber. Aiden Projects
Yeah, it was just glazing. That's what
he was doing with Walter
one time. Um I had a debate with Aiden
Projects about this Well, 700,000,
whatever. Um and I made the exact same
point. Why should we take it for granted
what he's saying? And he said, "Well,
because why We don't have any reason to
believe he's lying." Oh, we do. We do.
The reason is uh
about We actually have 300,000 total We
actually have 300,000 reasons, guys,
believe it or not, as to why Brandon
Buckingham is lying. So, yeah, we have
good reason to believe. We have good
reason to believe there's an incentive
for him to bend and possibly even break
the truth. We have very good reason to
believe that.
Oh, you don't have to take his word for
it, but checking with medical people
would be the best way to debunk things
if you were wanting to truly debunk him.
That's all I'm saying. Um
No, I agree. I agree. I mean people did
mention that there's like a like some
people with medical knowledge did in you
know, tell me that there's a lot of
stuff suspect with this um
image here, this this video here, right?
This this video here of Brandon. Like
the fact there's no pulse oximeter, the
fact there's no beeping, the fact that
it's like a very strangely quiet room.
>> Medical professionals have been in
contact. Um the fact that he's a puppy
pee mat. Like this is a puppy pee
training mat. I I showed this before,
but this here, this mat here, this is
what they use on puppies in order to uh
you know, train them to be house trained
and not pee indoors. Um
But I guess he's Oh, but it's a real
hospital. Totally. I mean, it could be.
Maybe the hospital is like run down and
cutting corners
and they're buying puppy pee training
mats.
Maybe.
Maybe. We don't I mean, but it's
possible. Yeah, this guy is like friends
with like a whole bunch of like
multi-millionaires, and they really
can't put together to pay for his pay
for his shirt.
They have to beg the fans. Okay.
hospital should be investigated if it's
real. But yeah, I mean, you know,
I don't know, guy.
I don't know. I mean, if this is the
best Brandon's uh
If this is the best Brandon's streams
can offer,
what does that say about Brandon?
It should It says he wastes his money on
drugs, realistically. Um
Anyway, anyway.
Anyway.
The hospital is training him to not pee
on the floor. That's a hopeless case,
man. That's a hopeless [__] case.
Also, yeah, the fact that it doesn't
look like he's in an ICU, etc., etc. Um
I listen, if it's the case if a medical
expert can probably come in and explain
all of the situation, like why this
isn't plugged in, it's not even plugged
in, etc. A medical expert probably could
come in and give people like me This guy
needs to get sped up cuz he's holy
[__] He's not going to get far in
life. He doesn't get it. don't believe
everything that's shown to them.
A medical expert could come in and
explain to me like why these things are
the way they are. And you know who
should be providing a medical expert,
guys? You know who should be providing
medical experts? Brandon. This [__]
[__] [__] clout chasing [__]
disgusting [__] manipulative loser,
pedophile defending [__] stupid
[__]
grifter
white
um N-words, you know, wigger. Like he
wants to be a rapper. He wants to be a
rapper. This [__] guy should be the
one providing us with a medical expert
before he even posts a video like this.
Like why did he post a video if he
hasn't shown the documents? We should
have proof. We should have proof. We
should have proof.
We should have proof. Obviously.
Obviously. Obviously.
The official documents he forged up.
Well, I'm not saying that Brandon should
show us medical documents. I'm saying
that Brandon should get a doctor, should
call a doctor, or get a medical expert
who has actual credentials. And so, if
they lie, unlike Brandon who if he lies
he just makes $200,000, if a medical
expert lies they can like lose their
license or whatever. They should get
someone like that to vouch for him or
show medical documents. That's what he
should do. That's what he should do.
That's what he should do.
Obviously, right? And people are like
sitting around. People are like [__]
talking about this guy like, "Well,
Perry, but if he lies Well, I guess I'll
I guess I'll get the tweet." But they
were saying, "Perry, if he lies If he
lies, then what practically happens to
him?" "Oh, yeah, that's so true. That's
so true." Like, you know, whatever
people do like a scam these days.
Whatever people do like a scam these
days, like nothing happens to them,
right? People don't just do like [__]
Bitcoin scams these days. People don't
just do a bunch of [__] uh Bitcoin
NFT [__] uh blockchain scams and
[__] whatever meme coin shits that
they do these days and just get away
with it. Yeah, that doesn't happen,
guys. So, it doesn't happen at all. You
know, don't drop into a meme coin and
like [__] grift like hundreds of
thousands of dollars from his [__]
audience of [__] help me. That
doesn't happen. Yeah, yeah, they they
will held accountable, too. Perry's
problem is lack of medication, okay?
This guy is like unmedicated ADHD.
action. He'll simply be He'll simply be
uh arrested. Oh, yeah, that's how it
went, right? Sure, man. Sure, man.
Sure, man. Anyway, anyway.
So, just to clarify just to clarify,
guys, I've never watched Leafy.
Furthermore, furthermore, I should also
clarify
my brother used to watch Leafy and I
didn't I thought he was a loser for
doing it. I thought he was a loser for
doing it. I'll just say that. I'll just
say that.
I will say that. That's an important
piece of information
to add to add.
Um
So, Bill Master here Bill Master here
says, "You are a comic." Says, "You are
a comic, guys."
To which I respond, "The only comic
and again, by I'm in Green Giant,
is Brandon asking people to pay for his
drug rehab." And there's a little like a
little interesting point that nobody
really focuses on. Everyone's like sweep
this part away. Everyone wants to like
try and hide this piece of information.
Everyone wants to try and like hide this
piece of information about like
Brandon's drug habits. And so, you know,
if he's if Brandon is going to I think
if Brandon is going to make a GoFundMe
on the premise that his life is ending,
he should be first of all open with what
the [__] medical information is
instead of just like having us take him
at his word. And second of all and
second of all,
he
should be honest about his medical
history. Should be honest about his
medical history. So, what is his medical
history, guys? Well, I'll tell you. I'll
tell you.
I need to find it. 1 second. While I do,
look at this beta hatred Aiden. 1
second.
Okay, we don't care. Just respond to the
[__] tweets, bro. It's like it's
literally like it's like no the rules.
It's literally like no the rules, right?
Boogie Boogie fake cancer. Boogie goes
on stream and says I I have my Boogie
like the original video like the
original video or whatever. Boogie's
like, "Guys, I don't know. I might have
cancer. I might have This is a terrible
segment, man.
You know, we're an hour into the stream,
guys. Um I know usually I do [__] I
don't do shields I try not to do
shields. I I try not to do shields
segments, but I'm not actually doing a
shield right now, guys. I'm actually
speaking to the many many people who are
watching the stream [__] seething
[__] blowing their [__] lid off.
The [__] steam kettle steam sound
effect is happening because I am daring
to point out that somebody claiming an
extreme medical Okay, what So, does guy
debate one of his fans or something? Is
that a thing?
Who the [__] is this?
on my
the [__]
Sure and That happened in here? Sweet
any reply
I know I do I do have
Nah, they didn't they didn't vote. They
got like 10 likes. Okay. No way that's
what Chronic sounds like. apparently
told you to delete them. No, no. I I I
thought Chronic was going to sound
way more of a freak.
I thought Chronic was going to sound
weird, but he doesn't.
It was
It was someone else, okay? I'm not
naming any names. Okay. Um So, you
deleted it and then you So, but you did
you did feel bad. It wasn't just cuz
they told you. It's cuz they felt bad.
Yeah, yeah. I did Well, they they kind
of like explained it to me. I did feel
bad. I felt like
>> Well, not even Indian. I knew he was
like British, but
I I I thought I thought he was going to
be like, you know,
he was going to be one of the muted
gang. You know the muted gang?
The muted gang who don't even dare talk
in VCs cuz their voices sound so [__]
weird, you know?
I had a moral obligation to apologize.
But then when I apologized, it didn't
feel like enough, so I donated to the
fundraiser.
>> How much did you donate? How much did
you donate? Uh So, before the before the
page went up, I donated like 10 quid to
his YouTube. And then
after his GoFundMe came up, I donated 15
to 20. Freddy Freddy and Louie just like
absolutely cut cut off over the voice
social shaming right there. 5
25 pounds.
>> So, you know he's like a millionaire,
right? Yeah, but it's like I don't know.
I just didn't I didn't feel good.
Uh
the apology was enough. Okay. I
understand. You don't have to give us
your details or anything. You're like a
student, right? You don't have like a
job. Yes.
So, like you don't really make much
money a month. So, I was like it's quite
the quite a sum to donate that much. Uh
well, I mean I don't know. I
I didn't feel like I felt like that
wasn't I don't feel like 10 pound or 5
pound was enough, so. But you think that
like he saw your tweets? YouTube YouTube
takes takes like 50% right, so. You
think he saw your tweets and he was
upset? Uh no, I don't think he
I don't think he saw my tweets, but I
did I think I did quote him. And that
made me feel bad, so. So, do you do good
things in your life? Yeah, I I I
volunteer at charity
at charity shop.
But you felt you had to do a good thing
You had to do a good thing to Brandon?
Listen Listen, if if he makes the ending
video, I'll probably regret it, but uh
yeah. Can you refund? Can you refund the
GoFundMe? Can you refund it? I'm not I'm
not refunding. I don't know, but like
is it possible to? I don't know. I don't
think I can. But can you But if it if it
is possible, why don't you? Because
I I feel bad about my tweet like I don't
You feel bad for your tweet, but why did
you But does that mean you have to don't
you don't have to donate just cuz you
feel bad, you know? Well, I mean I don't
know. I'm I'm mentally ill, man, okay?
25 pound made me feel Donating 25 pound
made me feel like a better person. Well,
I
You could give that money to me, for
example. I'm a better person than
Brandon, so I deserve that money. Yeah,
yeah, you do. And I'll probably don't
I'll probably donate
I don't You don't need to donate to me.
I I'm not trying to like pressure you or
anything.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm saying that that's money could be
better spent on like so many other
people. Probably. Probably. But you
could buy your mom like some flowers.
You could
buy a nice lady like a like a dinner or
lunch probably. And like you're
He hangs out with like You hate Sam
Hyde. You think he's a pedophile. He's
like he's besties with him. Yeah. Yeah.
And he's like You know he's this guy's
like this guy's like an edgy race lord
who like makes jokes about Indians
eating [__] or whatever. Yeah, I know.
But listen, I I I just felt like I
needed to be the bigger man, you know?
Right. Cuz like it's often often you
have like these things where like people
are anti-Indian and you like leave the
internet for a bit like on like Aiden's
server, for example. [clears throat]
Um and so I thought that like, you know,
the fact like that he's anti-Indian
would mean that you don't want to like
support him.
Well,
I mean I I wouldn't support him
normally, but I felt bad for what I did.
So, that's why that's why I did. Um Are
you sure that Do you think maybe that
like you have a good relationship with
the internet and social media? Probably
not. So, cuz like are you going to be
You seem You're not going to change. You
You say you don't have a good
relationship, but are you going to
change anything about it?
I mean what what what can I change? I
don't know. Well, because it seems like
you have this common pattern of like not
just in this case feeling bad, but like
often like somebody will say something
and you'll feel bad usually if they're
being anti-Indian, for example. You'll
think that you'll feel bad and you'll
like leave a server. Or in this case,
you'll feel bad and you'll delete
tweets. Maybe you just shouldn't be in
these spaces at all whatsoever if
they're causing you to feel emotional
I Well, I'm just I'm I'm very bored,
okay? I'm very bored. But do you not
have hobbies outside of this? I
I do have hobbies, but it's it I don't
spend like hours on them. Right, is
Chronic on his phone walking on like a
[__] dual carriageway or something? I
swear I keep hearing like the sound like
distant cars.
Yeah, but what are your hobbies? What
are your hobbies? Well, I mean I
I really
do that.
Well, I mean
you know, I I I exercise. I go gym.
Unlike you.
I used to go to the gym.
Hey, you go to the gym? I used to. You
used to. So, you Like what about like
creative stuff?
What about like creative stuff? Well, I
mean I I started doing like I started
get Well, I've only done a few
tutorials, but I've gotten into game
developing for fun. Like I don't know if
I'll ever be good at it, but
I'm I'm interested [music] in it.
Well, cuz I mean you think like the time
you spend like many hours a day on like
Discords and Twitter writing these
tweets, workshopping what the tweet
should be. You think you could like
focus on like the game dev stuff or
other things that you enjoy instead? I
could I could I could I could I could.
Uh I don't know. I'm I think I'm just
addicted to be honest.
Well, yeah, obviously that that doesn't
hit the same.
Like other hobbies don't quite hit the
same as fighting online. Everyone knows
this.
The The peaks and troughs of being in
constant internet fights.
That just hits different to any other
any other hobby. I'm just addicted to
Twitter. Cuz you're saying it's in a
joking way, but I see I think that's
like it's it's making you like worse.
>> I'm not saying it in a I'm saying it in
a serious way. I'm I'm saying it in a
serious way. I just think you maybe
should like cuz I appreciate when you
like, you know, tweet my stuff, for
example, or you like make interesting
tweets and stuff like that. content and
it gets like drama like Well, what what
what I've said is I'm just going to clip
people and I'm not going to like make
any tweet any replies or anything like
that. I'm just going to tweet clips. Um
Well, I guess that's good that you're
like setting boundaries, I guess. I just
think it's like I worry you're spending
all this time I've already seen him
breaking that. on this like this like
Twitter hobby, which is like causing you
like this like causing you, you know,
mental problems and um not time on like
more enjoyable stuff. Like do you have
Like do you have friends that you need?
Do you like hang out with them? I I do
have friends. I don't hang out with them
all the time, but I do have friends in
real life. Yes. Did you ask What do you
think they would think if you donated?
All right, I think I just dropped
frames. We should be back.
to Brandon. How do you think they would
You think um
Well, I I only have like I only know one
Indian person in real life, so. But what
what I only have one Indian friend, so
they probably won't care. No, well, most
of them won't care, sorry. Mm. Um Well,
I mean I guess to a certain extent I'm
glad that you're like not engaging in
the unhealthy way you have been. I just
hope that, you know, we don't see
another another week and I hope a month
doesn't go by and we don't see, "Oh,
Chronic left all these Discords and he's
like losing his own Well, I'm I'm I'm
I'm unlikely to leave your Discord. No,
no, I don't care about mine. I'm just
saying in general. I'm saying in
general. There's like this common trend
where people like I like that like noid
guy was like spook man or whatever and
that's like lame and it's like harassy,
but like it seems like, you You
people are getting to you and then you
leave and then you come back. Yeah, I
mean yeah, I think I'm probably going to
join more clubs. I'm I'm thinking I'll
join the volley the volleyball club at
my university. That might
be good for my mental health. That's
cool.
>> And physical well-being. All right.
Chronic wants to call in. I mean he's an
expert in this situation, so let's see
what he has to say.
>> I'm in rehab again?
>> Sai, uh
oh, yesterday you said, "I don't have
real life friends. I didn't need to make
friends." But now today on Perry because
he asked you about your spot, you say,
"Yeah, I don't actually have a lot of
friends in real
>> [laughter]
>> life." And you lied to What? Wait, Sai,
can you can you tell me what he said cuz
I couldn't hear him?
>> [laughter]
>> Chronic can't understand the fake Indian
accent.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> You said you're lying to me about having
IRL friends and you said on some Discord
that you don't have any IRL friends. No,
that's not true. I do have I do have
friends. I just don't interact with them
often.
>> say, "Sai, I need to make friends"?
Yeah, I need I I need more friends.
That's the thing. More friends who will
enjoy He probably has uh I'm going to
spirit read Chronic's life right now.
He's got a few friends, but they're like
total neeks. They don't go out that
much. They haven't got many friends
themselves. They're like not don't know
any [__] women.
I bet when Chronic talks about wanting
more friends, not having enough friends,
he's mainly talking about opportunities
to meet women. I would put money on
that.
That's usually what people are actually
complaining about. Everyone's got like a
few neek friends that they hang out
with.
Feel like hobbies that I enjoy.
>> How many friends are enough? How many
friends are enough for you to say, "Oh,
I don't need
>> Enough friends, well, I mean can you
have can you ever have enough friends? I
don't know. Yeah, you can have enough
friends. Would you say that
>> Well, I guess I'm online because I'm
bored. I'm bored.
>> Well, yeah, that's probably the reason
why I'm bored. Cuz I don't have many
friends. But then you say I have a lot
friends. So, which one is it? Uh
well, I mean I have friends, but I just
don't interact with them often. So, I
want more friends that I'll I can
interact with and enjoy more of my
hobbies with. That's why I want Chronic
told me he has never hugged a woman
once.
I mean yeah, there's probably increasing
number of guys like that. Yep. So, I
mean I'm guessing that is the issue. I'm
guessing that is the main issue when
he's talking about
you know, not having enough interaction
in real life, you know.
I'm sure he's got friends. It's it's
about women. Okay, and what's with the
volleyball? But aren't you part of a
debate club? Oh, yeah, I joined I joined
that, but
I haven't I've had assignments, so I
haven't been able to go yet. I'm I'm
trying I'm hoping it's on tomorrow, so I
can go tomorrow. So, you're like meaning
that you want to be more like Destiny.
All right, Cassie, that's don't be like
lame. No, no. All right. So, okay.
>> I can't hear what he's saying anyway.
Like he's really low. And I might I
might have to go soon cuz I got to get
some food. What are you going to eat,
love? What are you going to eat? Eat. Uh
probably something lame like pasta. All
right. Um
I have a problem. I have beef to pick
with Chronic Sonic. He said that the
only reason he wants peace in the Middle
East because he's tired that his Twitter
has a lot of tweets about uh Gaza. Like,
"Oh, this uh Sai, there's too much
tweets about Gaza and people dying. I'm
so tired of this." No, I know that's No,
that's that's
such a lie. I just said I wanted the I
wanted to be over. I never said there
was too many tweets about Gaza. I never
said that. That's such a [__] I
know that's
>> [laughter]
>> the only reason you want people to stop
dying because you're tired of seeing the
tweets about it. No, no, no.
I'm not tired of seeing the tweets about
Gaza. I'm but I I am I'm tired of like
people being angry at each other all the
time, so. Okay. But but obviously
obviously I'm I'm I I just want people
to learn peace and enjoy their lives.
Here's my advice for you if you want to
be a become a better person. What you
got GoFundMe? I don't have to shout into
the mic cuz I can't hear you, man. And
give it to Perry. That's the only way we
going to progress.
>> refund the GoFundMe. You're saying you
should refund the GoFundMe, Chronic.
That's another person saying that. I But
then I feel like [__] No, no. So, I
don't know if Wait a second.
If you just refund it and keep it to
yourself, yeah, you might feel like
[__] But refund it and give it to
Perry. Mhm.
Give it to who? Perry. Oh, Perry. Yeah.
Man, I don't I don't I don't know if I
want to refund it, to be honest.
>> But why why should you feel bad for what
you said? Why should you feel bad for
what you said about Brandon?
Uh because it it was not it's not nice
to like mock someone who's uh What's
wrong with being not nice? What's wrong
with not being nice? Uh I just want to
go to hell, man. I don't want to go to
hell.
>> So, whoever spoke to you,
they really did scare you. They really
did put the fear of God into you.
Well, that's Well, it's not just that. I
just I don't want to be hated by
everyone around me.
You don't want to be hated? Did Abba
message you about this? It was probably
Abba. I'm not saying he messaged me. It
was Abba. The other time he said the
other time he said he's not saying it.
It was Abba.
my messages were Abba and me messaging
her and her not responding back.
>> [snorts]
>> Most based thing I've ever heard. The
[laughter] most based thing I've ever
heard.
You do but like what Why just Brandon?
Why are you just you being mean to
Brandon? Haven't you been mean to Mr.
Mesker? He has cancer. You've been mean
to Rapsodies' wife. I've been I I I
literally haven't said a a word about
Mr. Mesker. I do not care about Mr.
Mesker.
Why why are you being mean to like
Strawbabe or whatever her name is or all
these VTubers?
>> Well, Well, Strawb's just
Well, Strawb's just a [__] and that
that's why.
>> Oh, you're going to hell for saying
that. You're going to hell for being so
rude towards women. Yeah, but she I mean
she's rude to people as well, so. Yeah,
Brandon's rude to people. Brandon's like
[__] exploits people all the time.
Yeah, but I I I know I'm not
>> he would rape Sneako's girlfriend. He
said he would rape Sneako's girlfriend.
Uh he never tweeted that. He never
apologized. That That is true, but And
he was like, "I just said run a train."
Like we don't know what that means. Um
so, he like all Yeah, so that's So, this
like he's literally I think you're
literally falling for the puppy dog
eyes. Like he's doing a routine where
he's like, "Guys, I'm I'm dying." We
have no proof he's dying anyway. He's
doing a routine and you're just like
you're like falling for it. You're like
a a fish on the hook right now. Yeah, I
mean am I worse for refunding though?
No, cuz that's I'm not you're
acknowledging you made a mistake. Okay.
It's called growth. Well, I mean I'll
think about it. I'll think about it. You
should. You should think about And And
yeah, I'll Maybe I'll donate Maybe I'll
donate to you. I don't know. We'll see.
We'll see. I'll think about it. As
long as Brandon doesn't get the money.
All right. Well, I guess if you're
thinking about it, that's all I can ask
for. So, all right. Well, thank you.
Wow, okay.
I think that's I think that's the
Perry-Brandon-back-and-forth done. I
think that's all I'm getting out of that
one.